hello Mexican rejects my name is greg
alba and to all you non mexicans welcome
to the channel i'm gonna talk about the
movie coco today coco is the latest
entry into Pixar's Disney animated films
boy do I have some opinions on this
movie right here heavy criticisms that's
for sure and today's video is sponsored
by none other than Stardust the Stardust
is this app that allows you to do
30-second reactions for any film TV show
or trailer just give me an idea here's
my 30 second review of Coco guys I just
watched Coco my eyes look like this
because I was crying so [ __ ] much
it's good to have movie yeah that's Greg
it's Tim it is such a beautiful film and
it has so many messages about like
family and pursuing your passions and
unconditional love
it's easily one of Pixar's best movies
I've ever seen and yeah what a great
film to watch on Thanksgiving I
absolutely love to recommend it for
everyone as you can tell I had a lot of
criticisms bill was a tearjerker that's
for sure
before comments start coming in because
that people have already been asking me
what I thought of
Olaf's frozen adventure well the
Stardust reaction will give you a better
idea than anything else I'll say it
right now here yep that's how I felt
about it but I just want to talk about
cocoa I did not know this was gonna be
playing before cocoa I was looking
forward to a Pixar animated short film
so if I've been prepped I might have
enjoyed it a little bit more but
honestly I'm not a big fan of frozen to
begin with there was some funny moments
to be had in here it's super corny super
cheesy super Disney I thought it went on
way too long and overall it felt like
just a promo to get you excited for
frozen - didn't really love it to be
honest so if you happen to have missed
out on one of the most viewed trailers
of the year that's Coco it's a story
about this little Mexican boy named
Miguel and Miguel he's really into his
guitar he's really into music he looks
up to this figure this really popular
figure they used to be like a big movie
star in Mexico and a famous musician
called Ernesto dela Cruz his family
though is the only family in Mexico that
hates music is anti music there
great-great-great-grandfather something
like that where the whole lineage starts
from he left them to become a big
musician so like music is outlawed
within this kids family honestly the
first act of this movie just takes place
in Mexico and then eventually
transitions into Dia del s mortis I
think that's how you say it I want to
just say Day of the Dead but if I don't
say that my girlfriend gets mad at me
because she's half Spanish but when
they're in Mexico you get a really good
sense for the family dynamics the
Mexican culture I'm not Mexican but I've
grown up in LA my entire life and
there's plenty of Mexican people out
here and a lot of my closest friends
over the years are Mexican so I've been
to a lot of family parties been around
the lifestyle plentiful I have no idea
what it's like to live specifically in
Mexican culture but I've gotten enough
great teases of what it must actually be
like seeing the portrayals of this kids
whole family the different personalities
or even the people he interacts with in
town it feels so authentic and really
feels like you're watching like a
Mexican family it's it's adorable that
[ __ ] it's so it's so super adorable I
was so on board for there that I wasn't
even was sitting around going when's
he's gonna get to Day of the Dead when's
he gonna start seeing the afterlife
I would have gladly watched just this
this story of a kid trying to get along
with his family and pursue his own
dreams because that alone was powerful
enough and then eventually transitions
where he wants to steal or nest Adela
Cruz's guitar and when he does do that
he somehow creates this portal where
he's able to go into the afterlife and
it's all and Day of the Dead format when
it goes into the world there it is
beautiful it's Pixar at its imaginary
best the world of the afterlife
this this movie kind of has it deals
with some dark stuff periodically and
you're dealing with the dead and they
all look dead they don't look like human
ghosts they they all pretty much have
the skeleton designs if you've ever seen
people celebrate dia del smortest they
put a lot of makeup on that kind of
gives a skeleton like presence instead
of them wearing makeup
that's just what they look like now in
the afterlife
I might be saying Iran but according to
my white friend John it might be dear
develop dia de los muertos I'm st. s huh
yeah dia de los muertos dia de los
muertos del Taco
enchilada remember this one kids yo
quiero Taco Bell you're probably too old
for that now but the 90s kids remember
that so when Miguel lands in the land of
the dead they do a lot of world
exploration there's a lot of neat tricks
they do with skeleton design and how
they move maneuver around places and
when the skeletons fall apart how they
assemble back together and there's a
wide variety of awesome personalities
that all honor and pay homage to like
Mexican families it's so freakin good in
the way it's written the script is so
solid here and the plot encounters this
guy you don't really trust this
trickster of sorts a conman of sorts
named Hector throughout this journey
he's basically unlocking his family
history because he sees a lot of his
family members that he's never met
because they've all passed on and he
goes on a very specific journey into
discovering about his family learning
about himself or he has to figure out
how to get back to the real world before
sunrise so this is ticking time clock to
it so he's slowly more of he's kind of
got that Marty McFly thing where he's
looking at the photo in his hands fading
but it's it's a skeleton throughout this
plot that's already a great plot like
there are plot elements and plot twists
that I just didn't see coming in terms
of the storytelling it's fantastic in
the plot Department the characters are
all voiced wonderfully they're written
wonderfully the Miguel character is one
of my favorite Pixar characters ever the
strength of this film is the various
themes that are explored throughout this
entire movie you get a lot of strong
themes about family values and what it
means to honor yourself and also
honoring your family and what's the fine
line between that because a lot of the
times we have our dreams are especially
for artistic types who have a specific
dream they want to pursue the families
disapproving of it do you cut out your
family how do you get your family to
understand do you need them to
understand so it has a lot of debates
and questions with that as well and then
you have the other themes of pursuing
your dreams and not giving up on your
dreams and for a film about Day of the
Dead they did something that I
I haven't personally thought about too
much in my real life which is about
honoring the dead and that's the whole
point of dia dwelleth more toast I've no
idea but the whole point day of the day
is to remember the dead honor the dead
and there's a lot of specific things
that deal with that plotline of honoring
the dead and how valuable and important
that is to remember your ancestry if
you're aware of where you come from if
you're aware of the importance of your
lineage it has a lot of themes of
forgiveness as well I feel like the last
half hours get crying kept crying I go
that's that there's always a new plot
thing that kept taking place that made
me keep crying and then finding out why
it's called the Coco was such a great
reveal oh man there's so much in this
movie that I can't recommend highly
enough the animation is great the
characters are great the music I'm not a
big fan of musicals in general I love
this show crazy ex-girlfriend and I love
lala land other than that I have a hard
time listing musicals I enjoy even when
it comes to Disney musicals nine times
out of ten I enjoy them but I don't
really care strongly about them that's
why the whole frozen whoa a short film
that went on for too long beforehand
kind of got on my nerves because I'm not
that invested in these musical numbers
this movie had such great musical
numbers and you really get to feel the
instruments at play too because a lot of
it is on the guitar and you feel that
guitar it is so moving
this film is enjoyable from the
beginning and then by the end your urine
just a powerful family film this is that
rare family film where you know that
there will be plenty of kids who will
enjoy the hell out of it but there's
probably going to be a lot of impactful
messages and themes that are will be
more relevant and stronger for adults so
in my personal opinion this is one of
Pixar's best films ever I haven't loved
a lot of the Pixar films as of late
other than monsters University in Cars 2
which were fantastic the other ones like
those films specifically I don't really
care for or even cars three finding dory
people love inside-out I personally
thought yeah it's enjoyable I don't love
inside-out this film is for kids but
it's also mature and that's a big reason
why I really appreciate it
it might take my
for best movie of the year honestly
we'll find out you know I still got a
few more movies to come back in December
go watch this movie it's a good date
movie it's a good family movie it's a
good movie to watch by yourself it's for
everyone it's the perfect holiday film
thanks for tuning in to the channel did
you see Co Co where would you rank it in
Pixar's long line of great films which
spot would you give it in the Pixar
ranking comment below subscribe to the
reel rejects please click that
notification bell you can follow us on
patreon you can become a patron on a jet
today it's awesome over there make sure
to follow us on the Stardust app
download it follow us first especially
for the first ones to tell you where the
first ones to really motivate you to
Google use it follow us first because
we're posting a lot over there and the
Stardust community is fantastic it's the
best best community Trump impression
into cocoa video we're done